[Music]
hey wisecrack Jared again and today
we're talking about the most famous
cyborg sorcerer laser swordsman in the
galaxy Darth Vader perhaps no villain in
the history of cinema has been more
iconic or more important to a franchise
is it the seductive voice of James Earl
Jones I his badass sci-fi samurai armor
his propensity for forced choking haters
or is it something else perhaps Anakin
Skywalker's descent to the dark side
resonates so powerfully because it
represents something we all face an
all-consuming fear of death I will even
learn to stop people from dying through
Vader Star Wars explores two different
philosophical responses to death by
exploring these competing ideologies we
can better understand how this whiny
little [ __ ]
person my name is Anakin came to be the
Dark Lord of the Sith welcome to his
wisecrack edition on the philosophy of
Darth Vader what will ultimately turn
Anakin Skywalker into Darth Vader is
fear fear of loss is a path to the dark
side specifically the fear of death in
his 1973 book the denial of death
cultural anthropologist Ernest Becker
argued that almost everything we do is a
way of managing the fear of our own
demise and the demise of those around us
this anxiety known as death denial is
especially present in Darth Vader and is
rooted as far back as his childhood when
we first meet Anakin Skywalker he's an
impossibly wise and articulate
nine-year-old boy genius with superhuman
piloting skills he's the product of a
virgin birth who was his father was not
funny he's smarter than any of the
adults around him and there's a prophecy
that suggests he might just be the
Messiah the prophecy of the one who will
bring balance to the force
you believe it's this boy oh by the way
Force aptitude is now measured in
midi-chlorians just so we can establish
from the very beginning that Anakin is
objectively more powerful than anybody
else the cells of the highest
concentration of midi-chlorians i've
seen in a life-form
but even young Jedi Jesus isn't immune
to being scared shitless of death and
carefully
Anakin's distress over his mother's
mortality will haunt him and as he gets
older this fear will become a fixation I
don't sleep well anymore because of your
mother I don't know why I keep dreaming
about him
Yoda figures out that this fear is going
to be a problem pretty early on you know
thoughts dwell on your mother afraid to
lose her I think mmm this could actually
explain why the Jedi are so hesitant to
train Anakin on account of his age the
boy will not pass the council's test
master he's too old although it's never
explained in Canon why only young
children are trained yes - OH
is too old the dialogue suggests that
Yoda and mace windu are concerned about
death denial and its ramifications for
young Anakin see when kids are youngest
it's easiest to indoctrinate them not to
fear death children according to
psychologist James a gram begin to
understand death as permanent between
the ages of five and nine but only as
something that happens to lame old
people say your mother Shmi it's only
later around the age of ten that kids
realized the permanence of death comes
for us all Anakin is nine able to
understand his mother's mortality and
likely on the cusp of understanding his
own the Jedi Council ultimately allows
obi-wan to train Anakin anyway but it
comes at a terrible cost
if Jedi are entrained beyond a certain
age because of their fear of death there
may be good reason according to Becker
human violence is a natural response to
death denial as he writes only
scapegoats can relieve one of his own
stark death fear doling out death gives
people a sense of control over it
whether that happens on the battlefield
or as regular all homicide for Anakin
that means a one-way ticket to the dark
side although it never made the final
cut the original script for Episode one
has Anakin saying something to Padme
that sums up his entire arc fear
attracts the fearful he was trying to
overcome his fear by squashing you be
less afraid and that works for you to a
point the script for shadows that Anakin
fearful of losing his loved ones will
try to overcome this anxiety by
attempting to squash death to gain a
sense of control over it
rather than actually being less afraid
when Anakin finds that his mother has
been mortally wounded by Tusken Raiders
laughter's the entire village and killed
them I killed them all they're dead this
kind of revenge makes sense according to
Becker who argues that killing other
people gives us the illusion that we can
control death us waging the fear that
the Jedi Council warned him about why'd
she have to die the more Anakin kills
the more death feels like something he
owns after Anakin's mother dies he
starts having anxiety dreams again this
time that Padme will die from childbirth
he's ready to blame himself for both
deaths his mother died after he left her
and he believes his wife will die
because he knocked her up you die in
childbirth
it's at this point that Anakin is given
a choice on how to deal with death the
Sith way or the Jedi way Anakin goes to
Yoda with his concerns what must I do
Master you'll train yourself to let go
of everything you fear to lose Yodas
answer comes straight out of Buddhism
not surprising considering that it's
said that Luke is specifically based
Yoda
on this Tibetan Buddhist Lama according
to the Buddhist texts the pali canon
Jarrah Marana the desire to escape old
age in death is a dangerously seductive
human impulse non-attachment or letting
go of your desires is the only way to
defeat it
and Yoda practices what he preaches when
he meets his own death and returned the
Jedi he is so chill about it sure when I
rest yes forever sleep becquer would
call Yoda a night of faith a term he
borrowed from the Danish existentialist
Soren Kierkegaard according to Becker
having real authentic faith in something
more powerful than death is a great way
to manage our terror for Kierkegaard
this meant faith in God for Yoda his non
attachment to Jarrah Marana is grounded
in his faith in the light side of the
force death is a natural part of life
rejoice for those around you who
transform into the force either way it's
not something you can choose this kind
of faith is in Becker's word a matter of
grace and not of human effort
Anakin doesn't have Yoda's faith so he
goes to Palpatine for an answer
the Sith approach is to embrace your
desires the Sith rely on the
passion for their strength in this case
the desire to prevent padme's death
aka death denial he could actually save
people from death in telling him an old
sif legend about Darth Plagueis the wise
Palpatine lets it slip that the dark
side of the force may enable you to
defeat death ironic you can save others
from death but not himself is it
possible to learn this power not from a
Jedi Anakin take sides and becomes a
Sith Lord on one condition
just help me save padme's life and again
sacrifices his name his loyalty to the
Jedi and even his conscience to learn
how to protect Padme from death in
refusing to accept death and it gonna
set down a dark path
he kills children his wife and even
tries to kill his mentor he has
completely sacrificed his personality
and values and has become little more
than a zombie trapped in a machine this
is the terminal point of death denial
according to Becker he writes the person
seeks to avoid death but he does it by
killing off so much of himself in so
large a spectrum of his action world
that he's actually isolating and
diminishing himself and becomes as
though dead left with nobody to protect
from death Darth Vader has become an
instrument of power and little else with
this in mind we can finally understand
what the hell obi-wan was doing in
episode 4 if the prequels were the story
of how the Jedi Order lost Anakin to
Palpatine because of his death denial
then it could be argued that Kenobi's
death was the orders way of confronting
Anakin's ill-fated choice look back at
their lightsaber duel on the Death Star
it doesn't look like Kenobi was actually
trying to kill Vader they spar for a few
minutes and then he basically offers
himself up as a sacrifice but not before
saying something cryptic you strike me
down I shall become all-powerful and
possibly imagine Vader swings the
lightsaber and then Kenobi is just sort
of raptured we could just say that the
first movie had a lower special effects
budget but Vader seems to be confused by
what just happened to Kenobi showed off
the fact that he had another solution
that made him well more powerful than
Vader could ever imagine seeing that
Kenobi was willing to embrace
steth offered an alternative to Vader's
death denial meanwhile the Sith still
hadn't figured out immortality at the
end of Revenge of the Sith we find out
exactly how Kenobi learned to cheat
death an old friend has been the path to
immortality one who has returned from
the netherworld of the force or old
master qui-gon
how to commune with him I will teach
this doesn't quite mean conquering death
in the traditional sense because Kenobi
and Yoda are still technically dead it's
more transcending death they can
interact with living Jedi by taking the
form of blue glowing force ghost
entities even Anakin gets to join the
squad after he redeems himself we can
also see this discrepancy between death
denial and death acceptance and how
Anakin and Luke confront death Anakin's
most telling confrontation with death
was when he indiscriminately killed the
Tusken Raiders to avenge his mother
ultimately Anna can even kill Padme in
his rage or she just died from bad
writing it isn't really clear which
she's done we don't know why she has
lost the will to live meanwhile Luke is
willing to give up his own life to avoid
turning into the thing he hates Iran
soon I'll be dead
and you with me when asked to kill Vader
by Darth Sidious he refuses this
willingness to accept death is what
truly separates a Jedi from a sip
it is only when Anakin takes a cue from
his son and learns to renounce his own
life that he embraces the reality of
death and conquers jarrah Marana but
you'll die nothing can stop that no
conclusion the story of Anakin Skywalker
is one that all of us have to live
through Jar Marana can rot our
personality strip us of our values and
drive us to do terrible things according
to Becker denial of death is responsible
for our drive to inflict violence on
each other to conquer and to control our
surroundings evil empires in the real
world and in the world of Star Wars Oh
their existence to our inability to
accept mortality but no matter how much
of ourselves we've invested in our
denial accepting the reality of death
can give us dignity build our courage
and expand our compassion it's never too
late for Darth Vader and it's never too
late for us as long as you're still
breathing you can come to terms with the
reality of death or deny it and risk
giving in to the dark side hey everyone
thanks for watching and all the love you
show for everything wisecrack